let's keep going I mean the the calls
have really been quite good today we
don't want to uh depart from that if you
can imagine that would be sad let's go
to mark from Los Angeles California Mark
what's going on keep us going here
hey David
hi you hear me yes okay yeah
um question uh first of all I just
wanted to know do you think that Mike
Lindale
um
has the remember you just got described
as sort of um persistent delusion that
is focused
oh paraphernia yeah because it was just
watching that interview first of all it
was exhausting congratulations to being
able to survive it because I mean after
a certain point of his he's so
relentless you just want to start
yelling at it I know because you just
can't he doesn't one of the things is
terrible about talking to him is that he
doesn't really listen to you and and try
to process what you're saying correct
and and try to come back with a a cogent
answer that actually pertains to what
you said he just has this Gish Gallop of
of of things to say and and it once you
try to once you knock something down
he denies that but not fully and yes
moves on to something else
a thing yeah and it's just like I was
just like you need help or or maybe
someone needs to interview him who
literally is just as rude as he is right
no it's difficult and I got both
positive and negative feedback about how
I handled the interview and the thing is
you have to kind of think about other
ways to handle it I could interrupt a
lot more but I already got some
criticism for interrupting too much I
could not interrupt at all in which case
we would have one Gish Gallop for 30
minutes and then we don't go absolutely
anywhere else
um you know you can always make the
argument that I could have been more
prepared and you can always be more
prepared but the problem is he can
always find some small fire to set with
something I haven't heard of no matter
how much prep I do so it is really
difficult to handle those interviews
yeah it's kind of reminiscent of what
Bill Maher was saying why he wouldn't
was it Bill Maher Sam Harris Sam Harris
Sam Harris exactly oh you know exactly
wow like like it's like telekinetics but
yeah that's exactly what I'm saying what
uh what Sam Harris is saying why he
won't have on anti-vaxxers right because
he's just you know they can always say
we're going to study from kathmandu's
Regional Hospital you know it's like I
don't know I didn't see that does it I
don't know what that is oh that's a win
right right absolutely yeah yeah yeah uh
are you originally from like New York or
Long Island
I'm originally from Washington DC oh
interesting Oh I thought I heard a
little a little bit of a New York accent
there no no no no no
no Washington DC born and raised Warren
Howard University Hospital went to
Howard University beautiful
um yeah
um and then the other thing I wanted to
say is um uh I was watching one of your
live feeds and you were playing some
voicemail
and there was a there was a black
gentleman who was was discussing how
um Herschel Walker fills in certain uh
very negative stereotypes about black
people and you want to play it too long
because it got it got a little dark I
was worried about mod like terms and
conditions having an issue on like some
of the platforms we were on like I know
the party was making but it could be the
type of thing that we got dinged for
okay I see I see because I was thinking
like I was actually watching MSNBC and
uh the one of the shows on there with uh
posted by um I forget her name it's a
black woman but uh but she um one of the
her guests actually made a really great
comment about the fact that Herschel
Walker is an insult to Black excellence
and and the the he fulfills many of the
stereotypes that white people have about
about black men he literally is a
walking and bottoming of almost every
single concept right that black men have
been strapped with since slavery you
know so um and that's when it's funny
enough you are you familiar with Rashad
Rishi it's beautiful yeah yeah
he actually tried to interview
um what's the guy's name he was he was
caught having sex with men what's his
name I have no idea I don't know I'm the
the guy that you've
you've been twice Jessica Peterson Jesse
Lee Peterson he didn't make it through
two two questions with Jesse Lee
Peterson I'm gonna have to check that
out because he could smell it a mile
away and if you're familiar with Aaron
Aaron Magruder's show The Boondocks he
very much embodies that um that
character that stereotype that he has on
there that sort of like you know it
gives a a visceral reaction to
African-Americans that's kind of
shocking and we immediately want to just
shut it down immediately because it's it
kind of calls back to some things that
are very dark well just listen you
really said it all uh I appreciate the
call I hope all is well in LA
yeah absolutely absolutely and of course
I love your show keeping the commentary
and um yeah I hope to hear did you make
did you did you see anything about the
debate that happened
um in Ohio yes we we streamed it like
Mark I gotta run because I got so many
people waiting all right my friend okay
okay thank you there's mark from LA with
the many many questions some of which
some of which I was able to answer